[Music]
rob kardashian reveals blac chyna left
their home and took baby dream and China
took everything that we built for the
nursery for the baby dream and she left
and she just left me alone et has a
timeline of robbing China's public
blowout right before Christmas I just al
Jackson [ __ ] yeah first China took to
snapchat on Saturday claiming her
Instagram page was allegedly hacked just
to let y'all know that's not me on my IG
page there's somebody that hacked me and
somebody's really really really really
really mad the anonymous user shared a
series of posts including this one that
read I am no longer with Rob I left him
and took the baby and did not let him
know
stay tuned for screenshots and messages
later flooding her Instagram account
with screenshots of old texts and direct
messages alleging she cheated on Rob
hours later Rob took to snapchat to
document his empty home so I get home
and China took the baby took the whole
nursery we built and we also built a
room for tea
but she took everything for King's room
as well
[Music]
the mama too responded to Rob's rent on
a new Instagram page with a lengthy post
explaining why she reached her breaking
point and left the couple's home I want
to do this
go ahead she wrote in part I'm done Rob
is mentally ill and refuses to seek help
he self-medicates which makes it worse I
have done nothing but help and loved him
from the beginning she added he stressed
me out my entire pregnancy accusing me
of cheating going crazy on me with
massive text blasts daily being an
absolute lunatic and then cover it up
with gifts I was verbally abused every
other day and I never not once cheated
on Rob Chyna ended her post saying she
wants the 29 year old reality star to
seek medical help Scott suggested
therapy I'm obviously more than willing
to do whatever it takes for China
[Music]
you